i thought that battle brewing over the
coveted mandates well as charles said it
could finally be
end up being decided in court the
administration says max vaccinations
will help finally get covet under
control here's the surgeon general
the data tells us that these
requirements work to increase
vaccinations number two a lot of
businesses
are actually relieved that these are
going into place this is what we've got
to do to get to the next phase of this
pandemic response so that we can get
through this and get back to normal once
and for all
former director of the centers for
disease control dr tom frieden joins us
now is president ceo of resolve to save
lives dr freda noes good to see you
nice to speak with you of course do you
think these mandates are necessary
well bottom line here delta is deadly
vaccines are remarkably effective and
mandates work look nobody likes being
told what to do but the fact is whether
or not you get vaccinated doesn't just
affect you
it also affects people you might spread
covert to whether that's the checkout
person at the supermarket or your kids
or teachers or a grandparent and it also
affects people who might not be able to
use health care
services because there are so many
people in with coving so yes mask
mandates work
vaccination is our most important way to
get past this pandemic to get back to
where we need to be and fundamentally we
want our kids to be in school learning
safely we want to be back at work
getting our jobs back and we need to
save lives
what would you say to someone watching
right now perhaps who's been reluctant
either fearful or another belief has
been resistant to getting a vaccination
there are a lot of people who have
questions how serious is covid how safe
is the vaccine and i think at this point
the data is extremely clear
kovid remains deadly in fact if you live
in florida or mississippi today you are
10 times more likely to be killed by
covid in the coming week as if you lived
in a state that has
sensible policies to protect people 10
times more likely to die
the coveted vaccination it's not
something that came on overnight this is
10 20 years of research that went into a
really super technology it's very
effective i've gotten one everyone in my
family has gotten fully vaccinated and i
really encourage people to get
vaccinated not just to protect yourself
but also people around you our economy
our kids ability to learn
jobs
this is a great discovery
no corners were cut we've had hundreds
of millions of people vaccinated and
serious
side effects are extraordinarily rare
there is no evidence of any long-term
negative consequences but i understand
that people have concerns they have
questions they're tired of covid and yes
many people who get covet aren't
seriously ill but far too many have died
in fact a new cdc study says you have 11
times more chance of being hospitalized
if you
are not vaccinated by covid and more
likely to die uh
from not having the vaccination and you
mentioned florida for example why is the
the risk the of death and of getting
coveted in florida as you just mentioned
why is it so high
as great as vaccines are and as
effective as the coveted vaccination is
it's not something that can be done all
on its own first off we need a much
higher proportion of people vaccinated
second delta is so infectious that in
some settings we need multiple layers of
protection that means masking up indoors
increasing ventilation testing
providing services to people who have
covid and to their contacts so that
chains of transmission can stop the
virus hasn't stopped killing people even
though we've gotten tired of hearing
about it because 18 months it's time we
feel to go out and ignore it but if we
ignore it it will come back to bite us
and you mentioned delta being deadly
what are your concerns about the new
variant that is apparently in
every state or almost every state the mu
spelled mu variant what is that
how bad is it and
are we protected against that
with the vaccines that we have
well one thing at a time okay delta is
still the dominant variant and it's so
infectious that it's difficult for other
variants to take over from it second are
vaccines work against the variants out
there they may work a little less well
but they still work extraordinarily well
but the big concern is that if we
continue to allow this virus to spread
around the u.s and around the world
without being controlled there is a high
likelihood that a future variant would
be even more deadly or dangerous than
delta that's why it's so important that
we increase vaccination that we have a
multi-layer way of protecting so we tamp
down spread and that we track the virus
and stay one step ahead of it
get the shot
wear your mask if you want to save your
life says dr tom frieden dr fredan
always good to see you thank you for
joining thank you
of course